SAAD ALI: Hi, everyone.
My name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software engineer
here at Google at KubeCon.
And here with me now is
Louis, an engineer on Istio.
Louis, can you
introduce yourself?
LOUIS RYAN: Hi, I'm Louis Ryan.
I work on Istio for Google--
I've been working on it since
the start of the project,
and just really excited
to be here and talk
about the project.
SAAD ALI: So we've been
hearing a lot about Istio.
What is it and how does it fit
into the KubeCon and Kubernetes
world?
LOUIS RYAN: So Istio is what
we call a service mesh, which
is a very abstract definition.
But what really Istio
does is it gives you
a way to kind of elevate
the networking concepts,
and allow you to manage how
services, micro-services, VMs,
and all these different
types of workloads
communicate with each other, and
apply policies to those things,
and extract telemetry
from that traffic.
So you get a much
deeper set of insights
about how your
network is behaving,
how your applications
are behaving,
and use that to drive
operational practices,
and improve the security
posture of your deployments.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
So it sounds like before
Istio, folks were basically
building custom logic into
every single application
to do things like logging
and network routing.
And with Istio, all of
that gets extracted out
of the applications in
one single control plain.
LOUIS RYAN: Yeah.
So the goal is to kind of
unburden application developers
from all these common
concerns that, depending
on how many platforms you
are building your application
code in, you would see a
high degree of variability
in the completeness or the
quality of those integrations
although they're pieces
of the infrastructure.
And so Istio hopes
to kind of give
a high, uniform base of
those type of capabilities
out of the box to
infrastructural operators.
So ideally , application
developers have to think a lot
less about those concerns,
and by definition,
their application code becomes
simpler over time by doing so.
And so it creates this
nice separation of concerns
in operations for companies.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
And is Istio
something that folks
should start with from the
beginning, or something they
should consider
later down the line
as they begin to get larger?
LOUIS RYAN: So we see
both at the same time,
almost by definition.
There are obviously
lots and lots
of really, really large
deployments out there,
but we also see
companies adopting
Istio from the beginning
just because people recognize
the value it has in their
development and operations
practices.
So we kind of see these
two different deployment
modalities.
When they adopt Greenfield--
and it's just very
natural, and they
don't have to go through
upgrade processes.
But Istio still has to be
able to be taken on-board
by a large deployment and
incrementally rolled out,
so we make sure we have features
that are there to support
those types of deployments.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
And what is the current
status of Istio?
LOUIS RYAN: So Istio, we went
1.0 in the summer of last year,
and we've been kind of
pushing, like any project,
to patch releases to support
stability, and reliability,
and scale.
The next major release we
have coming is in the end of--
sometime in January--
the 1.1 release.
There'll be some major
kind of performance
and architectural
improvements to the product.
So yeah, like any project,
it's moving forward,
we're adding features,
it's scaling up,
we're onboarding customers.
And it's just moving along.
SAAD ALI: And I heard recently
that GKE announced beta support
for Istio.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
LOUIS RYAN: Yeah.
So what-- we've been
working on this.
We kind of announced
it at Next last year,
and it went through
an alpha program.
And we just had the
beta announcement--
just providing a
nice kind of unified,
out-of-the-box installation and
management experience around
Istio to make it easy for GKE
customers to start using its
features.
We're really excited to get
that in the hands of customers
and get that feedback, because
Istio and open source projects,
without some help in install,
you have to do a bit of work.
And so on GCP itself,
we can take away
some of that installation
headache for people
and just make their
experience easier.
SAAD ALI: So what parts
of Istio does GKE manage?
Is it the deployment only
or does it go beyond that?
LOUIS RYAN: So currently, it's
the install and the upgrade.
And particularly, the
upgrade is important.
We will make sure that
the system automatically
upgrades as we add new
capabilities and new releases.
Over time, we'll make the
system even more managed.
That will include the ability to
scale up the amount of traffic,
and the number of pods, and
workloads, and other things
that GKE handles, and handle
multi-cluster deployments
and other more
complex topologies.
SAAD ALI: And in
terms of open source,
I know Istio has a
lot of contributions
from multiple companies
and independent folks.
Can you talk about the community
and what's going on there?
LOUIS RYAN: Yeah.
So Istio was born as
a community effort,
and so you see not just Google,
but IBM, Red Hat, Pivotal.
We use the Envoy Proxy from
Lyft, which obviously, Google
is also heavily invested in.
So there's a really
large community.
I've been wandering around
talking to people at the booths
here, and finding out
about integrations
they've written with Istio
that I didn't know existed.
So it's great to see the
kind of organic groundswell
of community support
around the project.
But it's very
community-driven, we
run very much like
Kubernetes does
in our processes
and our governance.
So it's an open project.
We're proud of the
fact that we're helping
to push open source forward.
SAAD ALI: Well,
it sounds awesome.
Let's shift gears a little
bit and talk about KubeCon.
This is not your first KubeCon.
LOUIS RYAN: This is
not my first KubeCon,
though each KubeCon does seem
to get exponentially larger.
So it's amazing--
I always like to go
around and talk to vendors
and see what they're
doing, and it's just
amazing to see how much
traction Kubernetes is getting,
and all the integrations
that that platform has
driven in the ecosystem.
But now I'm talking to
vendors about this Istio,
and so that's kind
of exciting for me.
SAAD ALI: Yeah.
I think you mentioned
that you haven't
had a chance to go to
any of the talks because
of the number of people that
are interested in talking
to you about Istio.
LOUIS RYAN: Yeah,
this was always
going to be kind of the
hallway track for me this year.
I'm here to represent Istio
and to talk about Google
and Google's use, and how
we're pushing the service mesh
story forward, so yes--
not a lot of talks,
though, I'm talking
tomorrow, so I at least
get to attend my own session.
SAAD ALI: What is that about?
LOUIS RYAN: So it's a
panel just discussing
where service mesh is,
what factors and forces
in the industry are driving
it, and where we all
think it's going.
And so there'll be some
folks from Linkerd talking
about their service
mesh products,
some folks from IBM, me,
and Zack from [INAUDIBLE]
will also be there.
SAAD ALI: Sounds like it will
be a great session for folks
interested in Istio then.
LOUIS RYAN: Yeah.
It's tomorrow around
11:40, I think.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
Keep an eye on the schedule.
And finally, what's your
favorite KubeCon memory?
LOUIS RYAN: So while this
is not my first KubeCon,
the very first KubeCon
I went to is actually
the inception moment for Istio.
We were thinking internally
about building an open source
service mesh product, and we
were looking at technologies
in the industry, and we had
found this kind of side project
that IBM was building called--
oh, I'm trying to remember
the name of it now.
[LAUGHING]
But anyway, we met the
project lead for that here,
and we just kind of
started spit balling
about creating this community
effort and rolling up together.
And within a week
of that meeting,
we had gotten the Istio
project off the ground.
So I have fond
memories of KubeCon
because that's where
Istio was born.
SAAD ALI: Istio was
born at KubeCon.
That is awesome.
Well, it was a pleasure
talking to you.
Thank you very much.
LOUIS RYAN: Yeah, it was great.
Thanks for having me.
SAAD ALI: And enjoy the
rest of your KubeCon.
LOUIS RYAN: All right.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]